[Music]
all right you should do a brendan chob
live read disaster
by the way
download the moneyline app right now get
your
money war tag going okay that's my
money's just now i'm betting with the
bank
right now we're coming out 25 grand
every quarter a hundred grand man with
money lying
he ordered straight from the block
do it mike do it
[ __ ] yeah
that beckham oh what happened
he's trying to do a live read and nobody
else
respects him no nobody respects him
so we listen here's the situation we're
still in the first quarter b
two minutes left he was doing a live
read and they're watching the game
where's sonny
i said
[Music]
call for a fade right right
you're not getting out of here did you
see that
he's a child
you want a ginger ale
and he goes nah do you mind should be
like no thanks but you see what he did
there it's a little thing but it shows
you
of
all that matters to him are his cool
friends listen how what he said to him
awesome
anybody want ginger ale
thank you mike
thank you mike thank you mike we're past
everybody mike tyson our friend
i call him mike yeah me and my boy mike
you're not getting out of here
calling for a fade wrong right right
marshall
anybody want ginger ale
thank you
you're not getting out of here
again i get i've been plugging this guy
forever but i gotta plug in two buttons
does really good with the shop stuff
please please please subscribe the two
buttons i cannot tell you
how much content we've got that so thank
you to two buttons and everyone
subscribe just search for two buttons
and type brandon shop his stuff will
come up